uh welcome everyone this is the meeting
of the cabinet at Northeast Derbyshire
District Council it's the 2nd of March
2023 three with me in the room I'm Alex
Dale I'm the leader of the council and
with me in the rubies counselor Alan
Powell councilor Charlotte Q pit and
councilor Jeremy Kenyon as well as
several officers who are supporting us
with a meeting uh and on screen we also
have councilor Mark Foster as well as
other officers who are supporting us
with the meeting
um first item is apologies for absence
I've received apologies from councilor
renick are there any others
any Declarations of interest from any
members
no okay uh minutes the last meeting I'll
move them as a true and accurate record
is there a second second gen you the
second dude podcast apparel all those in
favor
okay that's carried thanks very much uh
and then the next item that is a
medium-term financial plan uh budget
monitoring report from April to December
thank you chair yeah so as you all know
uh due to the extreme change of
circumstances compared to when this
current Year's budget was set because of
the war in Europe we introduced a
revised budget uh earlier a few months
back uh in that budget it would have
required uh 343 000 pounds to be taken
out of reserves to cover obviously
increased energy prices all of that
stuff uh due to work that's been ongoing
since then to reduce expenditure and
various other things that figure is now
reduced to 266 000 pounds so 117 000
pounds better than was anticipated
the expectation is that further work in
particular around Recruitment and
filling vacancies will reduce that even
further
um
possibly even to not needing to rely on
the reserves at all if things go very
very well
um a big piece of it is down to vacancy
management and obviously having unfilled
posts does have a service impact and a
lot of the work that officers are doing
is to mitigate that
and also their recruitment in at the
moment is particularly hard for some
posts as well so
um it's a mix of by intent and simply
because it's it's not been possible to
fill certain posts so overall uh these
impacts are being managed to minimize
the effect on Frontline services and I
propose uh the recommendation that we
note the report
thanks Council Canyon I'm happy to
Second just quick queries is there an
error in the title of the paper because
it refers to 2023 December it's a budget
monitoring report so presumably it's
April to the December 2022 is it
absolutely January December 2022 thanks
for the eagle eyes absolutely yeah if
you just amend that in the uh in the in
the Pac-Man or whatever and we'll
approve it otherwise uh everyone happy
without any questions no all those in
favor okay that's Carrie thanks very
much
uh the next item is the council plan uh
targets uh performance update uh doing
fairly well with this obviously as a
report makes clear
um 55 of the targets are on track uh two
percent have been achieved uh 38 have
been achieved previously uh and there is
a small number five percent that have
been flagged uh as requiring more work
basically but I'll hand over to Cath
jewelery in case you've got anything you
want to add a cap or give us a summary
of the paper
okay thank you chair so that's quite
right most targets are on track or been
achieved previously uh just a few that
are on alert uh just to
nothing I don't think there's anything
unexpected in the report to be fair uh
we know that with the Leisure centers
obviously we're doing a lot of
investment in all facilities and that's
obviously had some impact on
participation levels obviously that will
come to an end and uh participation will
pick up but it's just useful to know
that customers we've done the big survey
across all the centers and customer
satisfaction remains really high so it's
good that they're uh still pleased with
the services that being offered and
obviously enjoying the improved
facilities of some of the sites already
uh recycling as we know that's a
difficult Target and that's one that
obviously need to be a little tagged
under the new council plan at that time
uh but those factors affecting that
affecting all Council so contamination
levels and things like that so it's not
new unique to Northeast Derbyshire it's
a challenge that lots of councils are
facing
um and not really anything else further
to say to be honest I mean a lot of the
stuff has already been achieved just a
few issues that have highlighted and
though in the report for everyone to see
but just to note that the vast majority
of the targets uh are on track and
obviously quite a few be signed offer at
Q4 when this plan completes
brilliant thanks Kath
um any other comments from anyone
through a second
okay so Kenyan all those in favor
okay that's Carrie thank you very much
and then the next item is the Northeast
Derbyshire local development scheme uh
papers I'll hand over to cancer Cubit
for this
thanks Cher um yeah this is quite a
factual paper really a statutory one
it's basically just an update on and we
sort of obliged to provide it nationally
uh on the planning policies we have in
place and sort of funds to sort of you
know next steps or any reviews so in
particular uh the document sets out the
neighborhood plans that are in place
across the district I think there's five
of those in place and there are various
points in their life cycle uh obviously
the local plan uh which is in place
um and then
um it also sets out the supplementary
planning documents that we have
um and we're looking at reviewing some
of those and obviously potentially
bringing some other ones in uh later in
the year so yeah it's just a factual
document
um that we're required to produce just
to highlight residents what um documents
we make our decisions on and what's
potentially going to be reviewed or
re-looked at in the future so yeah happy
to sort of move the recommendations
um
okay I'm happy to Second any comments or
questions from anyone on that
no if not uh all those in favor
okay that's Carrie thank you very much
uh and then moving back to the agenda
uh there are no urgent items and
therefore I move that the public be
excluded from the meeting during the
discussion of the following items of
business to to avoid the disclosure to
them of exempt information as defined in
part one of schedule 12a the Local
Government Act
1972. is there a second for that
yeah okay so keep it all those in favor
okay thank you if we can just stop the
uh the live stream